a lot of times on Tik Tok I just see
these like crazy conspiracy theories
about me or just all these people just
you know I'm not too popular on Tik Tok
I guess but there was a woman um that I
guess destroyed me I guess I have been
destroyed on Tik Tok and I'm very
excited to see it I guess she gave me
some Lo logic and facts and I'm super
excited to see it enlighten me feminist
the people that believe in divorce go be
in long-term relationship ships leave
marriage for the people that actually
believe in For Better or For Worse for
richer or for poor in sickness and in
health till death do us part do you know
what drives me nuts about this clip that
she's operating off a premise that women
are getting married with the intention
of getting divorced they're not making
commitments with the intention of
breaking them they're just making
commitments to men who are careful not
to reveal themselves until after the
wedding is